Turkmenistan - A central Asian nation near the
Caspian sea - known for its rivaling nomadic
tribes, make it a commonplace for rising conflict
more often than not. But in Western Turkmenistan,
a small group of eight
rather peculiar tribes exist.
While at first glance, they may seem
to be just another group of nomads,
posing no threat to anyone aside from the other
opposing tribes in the immediate area, they are
anything but ordinary. Shrouded in mystery, it
is of SCP Foundation belief that they may be
a significant threat due to the many questions
still unanswered regarding their origins.
The most dire question of all isn’t
where they came from - but when.
SCP-3838 - Nomads of the 4th-Dimensional
Steppe is a collection of eight nomadic tribes,
occupying a small area of ten kilometers.
They all seem to be of similar origin,
but they are very different in behavior and in
the way that they interact with outsiders. While
multiple tribes can share the same space, they
don’t all exist in the space at the same time.
Periodically, the current tribe will perform
a ritual. With two flames near the entrance,
they will enter a yurt - and vanish. They
will soon be replaced by another tribe.
This new tribe will appear, seemingly
having traveled from another time,
though the Foundation is unable to
determine how exactly this ritual works.
All the tribes typically survive off the goats
and sheep in the area, and live in huts. Their
religions and traditions vary. Each group has its
own Khan and speaks the same dialect of Turkmen,
but interaction with the groups has
led to some bizarre revelations.
For one thing, their dialect was last
commonly spoken in the fifteenth century.
Some of these groups are humble traders. Others
are hostile and warlike. And the Foundation
rarely knows which they’ll be dealing with next.
While these groups all occupy the same place,
but not the same time, they have
developed unique ways around this issue.
The tribes seem to treat time the
same way other groups treat location,
forming treaties that allow them to
benefit when they switch into the space.
But while some choose peace, others choose war.
Observations made by the Foundation have
proven that when a new tribe appears,
violence and attacks from them are not only
common, but have been growing significantly
more volatile over time. Unlike many SCPs, the
Nomads of the 4th Dimensional Steppe are not
new. They have been occupying this land since at
least 1696, when they were first sighted. However,
initial sightings were not made by the
Foundation - which at that time, didn’t
exist in its current form. It was after a massive
battle approximately three millennia earlier,
that The Devan-e-Jaaduyih, or Office of Magic,
picked up reports of disappearing tents.
Over the years, they have slowly but consistently
amassed more and more knowledge of the
eight tribes now designated as SCP-3838.
Each tribe exists in the same geographic space,
but they come from a different era of history
- and bring with them different culture,
traditions, technology, and weaponry. The space
itself changed drastically, from its earliest
days as a holy site in the 15th century BCE,
to a bustling marketplace in the 1800s. The
marketplace is of particular interest to the
Foundation, as it is said to possess strange
and magical items like guns that shoot bolts of
light and arrows that follow their targets. Both
the 15th century holy site and the marketplace
are unique locations in time - they are the
only two places that manifest where the tribes
interact and hold councils and negotiations.
Each of these tribes bring unique challenges
and opportunities for the Foundation.
SCP-3838-1 is one of the smallest tribes, a humble
group of vendors. They only appear in the communal
marketplace in the 18th century, but are believed
to be from the second and third century CE,
and they are known as excellent potters. If
you see them, the odds are they’re trying to
sell you some nice earthenware pots. But while
they’re not relevant to the larger conflict,
they are a unique group for one reason - they
follow the Manichean religion instead of Islam,
and are strong believers in the religion’s
dualist battle between good and evil - the
latter being associated with the color red.
The second tribe has something unique.
SCP-3838-2 originates from closer to our
time, between the 12th and 18th century CE,
and they are the only tribe led entirely by women.
This matriarchal society participates in all the
standard tribal activities, including combat
and herding, and their lore speaks of a female
warrior who led in the initial great battle
thousands of years ago. Their territory is
among the largest of the tribes, but little is
known about them beyond that. They practice a
mix of traditional shamanism and Islam, and are
known for a ritual hunt with roots in Mongolia.
These women warriors are fierce, but
not at the center of the conflict.
But the tribes that grow closer to the
present day hold much more territory.
SCP-3838-3 is the current tribe, occupying the
land from between 1870 and 2054 CE - into the
future. It’s a simple tribe that seems to have
moved closer to a modern system of government.
Its Khan leads alongside a collection of lesser
governors advising him. The tribe is known for
their carpet-weaving skills, with their stunning
wares being a popular item for bartering in the
marketplace. But this group previously held much
more territory. Their position as a dominant force
is being threatened by a powerful force.
And that force is getting closer.
SCP-3838-4 is believed to occupy the land from
between 2054 and 3000 - the longest-lasting
tribe - and they didn’t get there by negotiations
and bartering. This tribe is feared by all the
other tribes, the only one not welcome in the
communal spaces, and it’s not hard to see why.
They’re hostile and warlike, attacking both other
tribes and Foundation members. If you look closely
at them - and are able to survive - you might
see that they’re dressed in human skins. Those
captured by them who survive are likely to wind
up as their slaves, which makes their army large
and virtually unconquerable. Their traditions
are mostly unknown, but they seem focused on
a funeral urn they protect at all costs - which
they claim contains the body of a fallen enemy.
But no empire lasts forever, and
something new will eventually rise.
SCP-3838-5 took over the space from 3000 to
3020, after the fall of their predecessors,
and they couldn’t be more different. This small,
peaceful tribe has few members left
and is mostly seen at the marketplace.
They’re known for being excellent cooks and
have good relations with most other tribes. The
Foundation is more likely to encounter them in the
Marketplace than in their own territory - which
is rapidly shrinking and barely has enough
room to farm or to build new settlements.
But the tribes were about to take a quantum leap.
The source of the strange and powerful weapons
at the Marketplace was a mystery - until the
Foundation met SCP-3838-6. This
tribe ruled from 3020 to 3450,
and were closely aligned with their predecessors.
A traditional Shi’ite muslim group unconcerned
with the mysticism of the other tribes,
their technology is powerful and advanced,
and they work with a secretive group called the
Empire for the Reclaimation of Islamic Artifacts.
Due to their advanced culture and intellectual
nature, they’re the most common point group
for interaction with the Foundation
- They are friendly and cooperative,
and the Foundation is careful to keep it that
way rather than meet them on the battlefield.
The next tribe is a mystery.
Originally, SCP-3838-7
existed from 3500 to 4100 CE.
They were a powerful and long-lasting
empire - but every empire ends,
and this one came to a crashing halt in a
conquest that eliminated all their territory
and left them as simple nomads, lost in time
and mostly existing within the marketplace
and as refugees within the other tribes. Or, when
it comes to the warlike SCP-3838-4, as captives.
The majority can be found within the small group
of SCP-3838-5. But the question remains - what
brought this tribe to an end? Most stories of this
period attribute the destruction to SCP-3838-4.
But recent events may tell a different story.
SCP-3838-8 is the most mysterious tribe of all
- and for good reason - we do not know when they
begin or end. They come from the far future, and
none of the other tribes communicate with them.
In fact, no members of SCP-3838-8 have ever been
encountered - however all of the other tribes know
of them, and many refer to them as the enemy at
the great battle. But no tribe hates them more
than the warriors of SCP-3838-4, who know them as
the enemy above all enemies. And unfortunately due
to SCP-3838-4’s warlike nature, the Foundation has
learned very little about this mysterious rival.
That is, until 2011.
Contact with SCP-3838-4 is rare, especially
non-hostile contact. Which is why it was a
surprise when a member of the tribe approached
the nearby research base with no army and no
weapons. He claimed to be an envoy - a rarity
for a tribe with little use for diplomats.
But he wanted to speak with the site director, and
thus, he was granted an interview with Dr. Rizvi.
The tribesman was uncommunicative and reserved
at first. It seemed as though he was having
trouble trusting Dr. Rizvi, but after a bit
of prodding by the doctor, the envoy warmed
up to him and began to speak.
What he shared was shocking.
There was a long history of mistrust between
the Foundation and SCP-3838-4, with many deaths
on both sides. But the Envoy was now insisting
that there had been a purpose for their raids.
He even seemed to regret the killings
of other tribes and referred to them
as “Brother.”. But he was there for a purpose.
He wanted to talk about the great battle,
and he referred to the aftermath, this strange
place out of time, not as a tribe or as territory.
But as a prison.
He claimed that they were imprisoning something
in a pocket of time - and something else,
another part of the whole, in another
reality. And they were the only ones who knew.
They guarded it ruthlessly,
and they guarded it alone.
Their only partner in this lonely battle was
SCP-3838-7, and their tribe was gone now. Their
burden was such that the other tribes would see
them as bloodthirsty monsters - but they were
anything but. They were the ones keeping
the actual bloodthirsty monsters at bay.
At least that was the story he gave,
while wearing the skins of his enemies.
It was impossible to make a firm deal
because of the lack of information,
but the Envoy was desperate. He claimed he
was bound by a higher power to not tell the
full story, but he asked the Foundation
to serve as an intermediary to help them
unite the tribes. His desperation was clear - Dr.
Rizvi was still skeptical, but he agreed to meet
with the other tribes. In the end, the tribes
were able to receive agreed upon concessions,
and in return, SCP-3838-4 stopped
its campaign of warlike expansion.
All seemed to be well - until
a new document was discovered.
Foundation operative John Callaghan was involved
in the Marketplace period during the 19th century,
and he wrote down a translation
of a song he heard repeatedly.
While it was known by many tribes, legend had
it that it originated with SCP-3838-8 - one of
the only known pieces of culture from the
mysterious tribe. It spoke of a mysterious
being named the Crimson Khan who one day
would return when seven seals were opened.
They forget the hallowed
words upon the death of time.
May they share the fate of those
who deny to me what's mine,
They forget the howling
chains that bind me safe away,
One of many old chanyus forgotten in this way.
They forget the steel swords
they used to cast me down,
They shall not forget again
before my flaming crown.
They forget the seven brides
that wait for my return,
Such loveliness is lost upon
the children of the urns.
They forget the seals that
are used to keep me still,
Only one remembers and is not bent to my will.
Seven seals, seven tribes, six
reclaimed, one shall be mine,
And ere the end of all your days
the Crimson Khan shall ride.
But who is the Crimson Khan? Researchers note a
lot of similarities between this unknown entity
and the Scarlet King, one of the SCP-001
proposals. Could they be one and the same?
The Foundation is keeping a close eye on
the situation, with a perimeter established
one kilometer away from the tribes’
territory. One entrance is available
for contact between the Foundation and the
tribes, but the perimeter is heavily armed
in case SCP-3838-4 gets aggressive again
- or in case any other threat emerges.
The focus is on diplomatic relations with
the current occupying tribe of SCP-3883-3,
but there are continued efforts at engaging
the tribe that will be their successor.
The Foundation has a hands-off policy with
regards to conflicts between the tribes.
With one exception.
The Foundation is keeping a close eye
out for any members of SCP-3838-8,
with orders to detain and interrogate them
on sight. But none have ever been seen,
and in fact, the Foundation doesn’t even know what
to look for. If they’re as powerful as believed,
given their feared reputation, they may already
be here, infiltrating the other tribes. But the
Foundation is determined to learn more about
them, and whatever they’re bringing with them.
They just hope to do it before the Crimson Khan
- whoever he may be - makes his presence known.
For more on another mysterious and dangerous
group, check out “SCP-1861 - The Crew of the
HMS Wintersheimer”, or watch “SCP-4007 - Unit
731” for another unusual group of warriors.